Dear friends,
you know my commitment and that of my group renew orup
to guarantee our values of the rule of law
and to prevail throughout Europe.
Independence of the judiciary,
equality
eh of citizens before the law
are 1 pillar of our Europe and our democracies.
We can never,
ever commit to these principles.
We can never weaken our judicial system.
What is happening in Spain
is 1 challenge for Europe.
We will examine the facts,
all the facts and nothing more than the facts.
We cannot take eh 1 risk and there is
too many questions now unanswered,
all in Europe
we have the right to choose the best possible guarantees
for the proper functioning of the judiciary.
We 0 deputies are the guardians
of these principles and in Spain
eh everywhere in Europe
I would also like to count on the work of
your MEPs as citizens
to be the
the guardians of our European values
in Spain,
long live Spain,
long live Europe!